sony on
[Musique]
ne peut plus durer
tu m'avais promis tout a mal à les
reprendre sa marche
normalement
doit tu ne respectent en rien
son renard mama écoute si tu ne t'étais
pas mondialement je descends dans mamma
là il me fait penser terrain
tu me parles oui je te pares été et je
crie même j'en ai assez
tu en as assez et de coin est en fait un
cas majeurs devaient reprendre sa taille
normale
ou m'écrit casimir elle maigrit
lentement elle a déjà perdu
2 cm je sais ce n'est pas beaucoup mais
a voulu manger tous les restes du dîner
et ça l'a empêché de me griller très
vite voilà tu me prends pour un imbécile
tu veux me faire croire qu'une malle
grandir ou grossir selon ce qu'elle
mange c'est pourtant bien ce qui
t'arrive à toi moi moi moi moi c'est pas
pareil je suis vivant j'ai une bouche à
l'estomac candidats mal c'est seulement
du bois mort
quoi tu te dis je vois et
c'est horrible casimir mais je n'ai même
pas vu mourir voilà la photo casimir
laisse moi avec les chagrins
s'ils sont en armes au nom c'est bien la
dernière fois que j'accepte ma maman l'a
bien
apprécié ce que j'ai fait pour toi
léonard jeunes et recueillie chez moi je
t'ai donné ma maison et maintenant tu me
met dehors à grasse pour me voilà bien
récompensés pas dieu
[Musique]
[Rires]
vous avez vu
ce monstre préhistorique un des plus
mauvais caractère qui soit il n'a aucun
sens de l'humour quand c'est lui qui
fait des farces aux autres ils les
trouvent toujours très drôle mais quand
on lui en fait à lui alors là il se mit
aussitôt reconnaît c'est curieux n'est
ce pas enfin vous en connaissez vous des
gens comme ça qui réagissent
à vrai dire moi j'en connais beaucoup
le principal c'est que je m'amuse bien
je sais on dit que les plaisanteries les
plus courtes sont les meilleures je vais
quand même faire du rhin seul un peu
plus longtemps
sans l'émission
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment passé une bonne soirée à
moi aussi ça il est vrai que le repas
que nous a mitonné léonard était
extraordinaire sans oublier la tête de
casimir quand il s'est aperçu que laval
était presque aussi grande que sa maison
c'est vrai on marque doivent torrijos
ordre dans les casinos
or mes amis ça ne peut plus durer
biac que se passe-t-il casimir ferrer
s'ennuie je ne peux plus être chez moi
c'est moi chez moi chez moi chez soi
chez lui chez toi je lis tout chez lui
six oui c'est ça
son histoire n'est pas très clair
casimir d'abord ce n'est pas une
histoire et c'est très clair léonard
plus de démonter sa malle géant je ne
peux plus le supporter mais enfin
casimir c'était une plaisanterie tu ne
devrais pas te mettre en colère parce
qu'il à dire je n'ai plus de place pour
prendre mes repères je ne peux plus
faire ma gymnastique le matin aucun mur
sépare très grave une ak fertat
gymnastique je sais pas moi ici dans le
genre oui c'est ça et puis moi je vais
te préparer à bong lobé boulga au merci
c'est très gentil je vais commencer tout
de suite par la gymnastique et bien tu
vois casimir sasa rouge et puis ici
aussi tu es chez toi et en plus tu
vraiment toute la place volume c'est
vrai je n'y pense pas assez souvent mon
rang julie julie tu m'aime beaucoup
d'heures de banales et 206 ça car j'ai
trop faim alors que j'ai fini ma
gymnastique a qu'à aller
2-3 campétois sur les restes de 3,4 tu
respires
tout ça quand j'ai fini ma chemise à stx
est toujours un peu fatigué j'aime bien
avoir mon lit pour m'allonger quelques
instants malheureusement ici mais après
tout je pense pourquoi pas ça me donne
une idée je lui tu as déjà fini moi j'ai
à peine de commencer non mais je
mangeais mon boulot bulgare plus car je
vais d'abord faire mon déménagement au
caucase une étude qui tuent des ménages
oui
faire du camping ah ça c'est une très
bonne idée ah oui effectivement c'est
une idée amusante et puis quand leonard
va se retrouver tout seul chez casimir
il va tellement s'ennuyer que très vite
il va démolir la mâle géante oui et puis
il ya deux tellement joli endroit ici
dix mois casimir choisis ton endroit ah
oui oui ce sera ici
vous avez bien dit quand j'étais chez
moi alors ici je vais d'abord mecs m'ont
prend les mines casimir mais enfin les
enfants ont pu jouer tu fous là tard
d'aller chez sauramps parfaitement bien
là mais non pas du tout bon pas miramont
pièce ma grande armoire il a très bien
servi dans les paquets sans faute pour
pu s'approcher de moi je mettrais mon
coffre à jouer comme ça ça me fera de
coffre avec le kiosque de julie pensez
vous dehimi exactement ce que nous le
répétons depuis cinq minutes et que tu
fais semblant de ne pas entendre il n'en
est pas question
mais si je je je n'ai plus de maison
j'ai été mis à la porte de chez moi
alors qu'en plus vous avez dit que
c'était ici chez moi donc je vais
m'installer dans ce jardin fait si vous
n'êtes pas content vous n'avez qu'à les
voir leonard
c'est lui le responsable a rien du tout
nous allons lui dire deux mots à srna
rien j'y viendrai te suis parfait mais
pour nous on travaille à
la mi
temps je suis bien
on sent les mines
les larges et là on oui entre françois
orangerie
bonjour julie non jour l'oea
n'avait l'air devient mauvaise humeur
vous n'avez pas trouvé mon dîner bon
comptines et est excellent mais léonard
nous sommes venus te dire que les
plaisanteries les plus courtes sont les
meilleures il faut absolument que tu
reprennes immédiatement tamales habituel
et que casimir viennent habiter chez lui
il vient moi je pense au contraire
que plus une plaisanterie est long plus
elle me fait haïr et comme je suis un
renard libre dans unis le livre je fais
les plaisanteries que tu es libre top
que ce que tu fais n'empêche pas les
autres d'être libre il ne faut pas
confondre liberté et égoïsme sans le mot
vient julie laissons ce renard il est
vraiment trop désagréable bien mal
à m'en
aller bien
je suis un peu ennuyé pont juil puis je
trouve que maître françois en colère
c'est très drôle ça m'a donné
je n'ai plus rien omis fond j lui
acheter des gâteaux je vais passer par
mon tunnel ça m'évitera de rencontrer
françois et casimir on sent le mieux
alors
qu'est ce que c'est que tout ce bric à
brac c'est mon mobilier 20 le jardin est
fichue
saint-casimir du coup on se croirait
chômage est ici chez un brocanteur me
tuera plus mal ton lit ou ailleurs un
peu plus patient dans le fond comme un
bien quand j'habitais repart et je ne
toucherai bien molli ici tu verras c'est
sûr que je vais bien dormir
mais qu'est ce qui t'arrive le fonds
mondiaux ce qui bouge bien sûr ce mois
léonard vient acheter de la terre il
dort pas d'audace casimir j'arrive
maintien sans trottoirs séparation
d'accord
enfin je lui
dis oh
je lis j'ai pas votre sens pasqua
précédente il est plus court sont les
ménard fait prêt
les
oui
oh oui
non
ouah
à
[Musique]